there were seven in 34 last year which
was the worth of the lay still
he'll kiss another students to one
okita-san be adding some firstly to the
night yoke is gonna try it again at
Portland Friday at Utah Saturday hope
it's gonna take another one unbelievable
that one's good now Harris turns the
corner yo kids try it again
he doesn t go kids even with 2.5 m on
that the shots about a 10 flopson gets
the call yeah and then then I'm not sure
them legs want to go all the way over
I'll lift the weight in the judge maybe
gives him a bad score of that shot in a
row for the Nuggets distance 21 first
half points per Nicola y'all kitch yeah
Arastoo yoga council I'll check that
it's Mozgov once you spin move thanks it
here's who one way then to spin then
we'll see that little plump little
shoulder bump right there Cola is so
good with the touch he got bump and he's
still hit he hadn't got to the room
points 25 minutes ago Yogesh picked up
by DeMarre Carroll over the Millsap
should take the jumper right over Moscow
he's got
Yogesh has been spectacular on offense
chilliness typically open janitors can't
get on the ball that's negative at
sketball yoke it's to Harris legs we've
said it all along when you get good deep
it seemed that Fred it seemed like the
off it starts clicking perfect play let
me look at that pass I mean the Burt's
got his head completely turn back Gary
back seven for him just looking
surveying give us a bill sat Millsap for
three yes now yo get you the pivot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
for the man they call the Joker 41
Nicola yoke